[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
comedians never responsibility to speak
recklessly I don't know if y'all know
about me but I was I used to be a street
pharmaceutical rep which is very frowned
upon
I started doing stand-up comedy when I
was 14.
I'll never forget the first time I was
on stage the sign was a mistake I blew
it with a sign
it's too big
I don't think any other country could
produce this many comedians I could have
sex in a river of blood
and unbeknownst to many people in this
audience I don't think there's opinion
that it exists in this country that is
not represented in a comedy club by
somebody
that's kind of the perfect setup though
right
[Music]
2022 is coming to an end and boy was it
a great year for comedy this year
brought us endless amounts of hilarious
podcast moments crowd work clips and
live shows but above all of that this
was a historic year for stand-up
specials that's why in today's video
we're breaking down the top five comedy
specials from 2022 starting right now
with number five this list would not be
complete without mentioning Norm
Macdonald nothing special it wasn't a
traditional special there wasn't even an
audience it was recorded on Zoom but it
was still one of the most heartfelt
moments in comedy history the only time
it seems you ever survive
a airplane crash is if you crash into
the Andes you know that's even worse
because you know you you then you have
to you have to fight with the moral
quandary of cannibalism
which I am against by the way I'm not if
you know anything about my work you will
know uh my uh my tireless Devotion to
the anti-cannibalism cause but I'm not
going to use this as a a bully pulpit
most of you are adults and you've
cemented your view is on cannibalism I
like to go for the kids you know the
young people I go all across this great
country and I I go to the schools and I
talk to the children you know and I tell
them I go listen you might think it's
cool to uh eat your buddy in algebra
class
and I'm not gonna lie to you you will be
the talk of the school for a few years
but I what about the future what about
the future I tell them I think everyone
can agree the story behind Norm
Macdonald nothing special really is what
makes it so special Norm Macdonald has
cancer he doesn't tell anybody in the
world nobody knows that in September of
2021 he suddenly passes away in March of
2022 this comes out on Netflix Norm
Macdonald nothing special it's a video
that he recorded by himself all by
himself knowing that people would only
watch it after he was already gone it's
enough to make a man cry number four on
our list this year is Stavros halkias
live at the lodge room this special
premiered on YouTube on June 5th 2022 it
currently stands at 4.4 million views
and is 53 minutes long I had a pretty
productive pandemic I'm not gonna lie I
uh I lost 50 pounds during the pandemic
wow
thank you yeah
that was that was during the second half
of the pandemic during the first half I
gained 45 pounds so
I kind of took the scenic route to
losing five pounds
yeah dude I was [ __ ] as soon as it
happened there was no chance
there was no chance I wasn't gonna get
fat as hell you know what I mean
yeah because it was a scary time right
we're all you know we're cooped up we're
anxious we don't know what's gonna
happen and I'm a very emotional eater
you know like I use food as drugs
uh but I also use drugs as drugs you
know what I mean
like you shouldn't be shouldn't be able
to eat a whole pizza on cocaine but
I'm five for five you know what I mean
I power through every time
yeah I remember the first part of the
pandemic was all Tiger King and online
shopping remember it was like I swear to
God if this [ __ ] up Cinco de Mayo I'm
gonna be pissed
remember that I got fat as hell during
that part
and I was [ __ ] up the whole time I was
just taking Edibles like they were birth
control you know
like an alarm would go off on my phone
I'd be like whoa time for 90 milligrams
jeez I almost had a thought today that
that was the close one
I almost reflected today
it didn't help but they made you feel
like a hero for ordering takeout by the
way
remember that
every commercial is like support your
local restaurants we need you right now
it's like oh my god well
is called upon I will serve
hello yes Marlo Maine fast hurry
we have to combat the xenophobia the
Chinese are up against right now
more dumplings I have to stop Asian hate
coming in at the number three spot this
year is Bill Burr Live at Red Rocks this
is Netflix special number six for Bill
Burr it's an hour and 20 minutes long
premiered on July 12 2022 and was
directed by Mike binder other than that
there's really not that much else to say
about it it's a classic billboard
Netflix special he's a living legend the
venue is sick Live at Red Rocks
you won't be disappointed
professional
s going like I don't understand how come
female athletes don't make as much as
male professional athletes right and all
of these men had to sit there and act
like they didn't know what the answer
was
they had to sit there like dumbfounded
like oh
why is that
that is a conundrum I have I have no
idea
literally I'm sitting at home screaming
at the TV because you don't sound any
[ __ ] ticket
nobody is going to women's soccer games
you're playing in a 20 000 seed Arena
1500 people show up that's not a good
night
the promoter lost his [ __ ] ass on
that kick
there are two specials that came out
this year that in my opinion were heads
and shoulders Above the Rest that both
easily could have been listed number one
on this list but coming in number two on
our list this year Andrew Schultz
infamous
this is the moment you've all been awake
[Applause]
[Applause]
New York City
he is the reigning
defending on disputed
heavyweight champion of the world the
one the only the infamous
[Music]
[Applause]
one two three
two four
four
three hours
[Applause]
that's how you start a [ __ ] show
right there but
this will go down as one of the best
stand-up specials this decade the
marketing and production behind this was
out of this world it's going to change
the comedy landscape forever and that's
not even mentioning how [ __ ] funny
the material was Andrew Schultz first
debuted infamous on his own website but
it was uploaded to YouTube on September
25th 2022 and already has 12 million
views in just three months which is nuts
and now the number one special from 2022
and by far one of the more talked about
stand-up events from this entire past
year Ari shaffir Jew I mean let's let's
start at the beginning it's the only way
to do this
Adam and Eve you guys know that story
okay if you know that story this is all
gonna go over your head tonight
if you haven't seen a special
um go watch it it's it's my boy Ari
shaffir
um he's got one of the best comedy
specials that I've seen in a long time I
think it's your best work ever I really
do Rock Solid dude it's so good going to
a seminary called the Yeshiva in
Jerusalem for two years after high
school so you go to study if you want to
become a rabbi uh spoiler alert it did
not pick
orange if you're special on YouTube it's
called Jew okay it's about learning
about Judaism through comedy that's the
new way that comedy special is gonna get
out it's like we gotta have to see him
and teach you something that's a great
special our Shakira special Jew uh even
Kanye likes it I saw it it's it's very
good I think it might be your best work
come on in here he comes Ari shafir how
do I get up and give you the middle give
the middle okay I saw it I came I
watched you do it live my buddy Steve uh
he's Catholic he's a comic and uh I made
a Catholic joke once and he got I got
off stage he had nothing but you know so
I got off stage he was like Ari what do
we have to do to make you stop making
fun of campus and I was like one thing
this material took over four years of
work to perfectly craft into a 90-minute
theme special about the origins of
religion and Judaism the set design the
marketing and especially the jokes all
came together to create basically the
perfect special if you're into comedy
there's a zero percent chance you
haven't heard of Irish Affair Jew and it
just came out in November like I said at
the beginning of this video it was a
tremendous year for comedy so there's
definitely a ton of honorable mentions
that deserve to be mentioned in this
video for example domino effect mom love
this year's material Dave Chappelle
Sticks and Stones came out this year and
that literally impacted American culture
for a while there that was crazy that
was this year that feels like so long
ago Killian keeves format their sketch
show as a special this year so if you
count that as this comedy special that
came out this year too there was just a
ton a ton a ton of Great Moments in
comedy this year also a great year for
uh cheetah print shirts in your comedy
special Stavros and Schultz both rocking
that so
yeah that's about it for this video let
me know what your top five is in order
in the comments thank you so much for
watching this video and thank you for
following along the joke world channel
for this past year of Comedy uh staying
in the comedy Loop getting all your
comedy news all in one place the sports
center of Comedy if you will
um that's about it we'll see you Monday
with the comedy news and if you're
interested in these free joke World
stickers go fill out the form in our
Instagram bio and we'll send you those
in the mail right away completely free
all right thanks again
[Music]
foreign
[Music]